following the Jefferson Trade Center
Mission with Captain Lewis General
Anderson has come to the realization
that the true sons are no match for the
division or the Black Tusk so he has
reached out to Natalia Sokolova in an
attempt to team up
Natalia has sent out a team of Black
Tusk operatives to assess and work out
the viability of this potential new
alliance
the first of which is Matthias trig
Snyder
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
was born and raised in Copenhagen
Denmark from early on he was seen as a
gifted child with a particular interest
in mathematics at the age of 12 he moved
to the United States to study at MIT
18 he graduated with the Masters in
electrical engineering and would become
the Department's youngest associate
professor
his theoretical work on perpetual energy
turbines eventually caught the eye of
the defense department and he would be
brought in to consult with Dapper
scientists on several classified
projects
but it wasn't long before his skills
were noticed by others
trick would be head hunted and recruited
by the black task private military
company to find alternative solutions
for powering their hovercrafts during
off-grid and prolonged deployment
operations
for the first time we've now been given
a visual of General Anderson what is
interesting to notice is that he is
wearing General Antoine ridgeway's
jacket
highly to his personality and intentions
the first moment he had he grabbed
rejoy's jacket as a symbolic gesture to
assume the mantle of control over the
true Sons others would have proven their
Worth or would have been the obvious
choice as his successor but Anderson
obviously thought he needed this as
further evidence to support his claim
regardless Anderson has now decided that
the true Sons can no longer continue
with their plans not without the support
of others
the division in the Black Tusk have
proven that the true sons are no match
so Anderson reached out to Natalia to
work out an alliance
however given our last interactions with
him Captain Lewis is likely to have some
issues with this
Lewis assisted Us in taking down one of
Natalia's operatives after his team was
taken out at the Jefferson Trade Center
but for now laws takes his orders and
meets up with one of the black task
operatives who were assessing the true
sun's position
what's your favorite geometric shape I
don't know
interesting practical steady strong
stable
one of the hardest shapes to break a a
shape can tell you a lot about a person
what's yours technically it's a plain
curve but there's nothing more beautiful
than a parabola
you see a lot of parallel
work every time I take a shot you don't
think it's weird that we were shooting
at each other last week and now we're
supposed to be best buddies I think it's
weird the true Sons thought they could
stop us better to get on board than get
run over exactly you really are a
triangle
foreign
agents receive and tell that trig is
located somewhere in Southwest
Washington DC
after taking out a number of freshly
acquired outposts held by the Black Tusk
they would discover that Trigg had been
hunkered down in the Jefferson Plaza
the Black Tusk presence was heavy and
they had well fortified the area but the
agents were able to slowly Advance
through the facility until they
eventually met up with the target face
to face
trick was prepared to have more than
just a gunfight as he had explosive
devices strapped all over his armor
however these certainly didn't work in
his favor before he had a chance to use
them a few quick bursts from the agents
would cause them to detonate stripping
him off his armor leaving him open to
the final kill shot
as part of her assessment of the true
Sons Natalia questions the Loyalty of
one of Anderson's most trusted
lieutenants
I'm worried about your man Lewis
he's a pencil Pusher nothing to worry
about he allied with the division during
Bonnie's test
momentary lapse of judgment
why are you protecting him he's loyal he
knows where all the bodies are buried he
won't be a problem if you're wrong about
where his loyalties lie at least he can
tell you where to bury his body
the Anderson won't have a bar of it
Lewis is one of the good ones someone
who's been there from the very beginning
someone he trusts
he would need more than a little
speculation in order to act on such an
idea
and that's exactly what Natalia would
bring
you're right those were my choices and I
have to live with them but it's not too
late to make different choices what the
hell are you talking about can we meet
you were right
Louis may be a problem I'm glad you
agree
you want me to uh take care of it not
yet
watch him and see what he does next
better to lead you to the Rat's Nest
than a rat
it would seem that whatever side Lewis
is playing for his options are now
becoming pretty Limited
as someone who's extremely loyal to the
true Sons they have now taken a turn
under Anderson's leadership to team up
with the regime that Lewis doesn't agree
with
so at this stage it would appear that
the Jefferson Trade Center mission where
he teamed up with the division won't be
a one-off I imagine the division will be
involved in rescuing him in a future
Mission fully bringing him over to our
side potentially with other true sons
that are loyal to him he can't be the
only one who is unhappy with the
direction that the new leader is taking
them
season 10 seems to be taking a similar
direction to season 9 with the minor
targets are just that minor characters
there isn't much information on trick he
was more of a vessel to carry other
comms leading towards the final Manhunt
Target General Anderson
well this is fairly common practice I
would have liked to hear a little more
about trig he had potential to be an
interesting addition to the story but
who knows maybe we'll hear more about
him later they've certainly left it
incredibly open much like many and now
look at him he's playing a much larger
part in this season but I'll talk more
about that in another video thank you
very much for watching and I'll catch
you in the next one cheers
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]